this is Startalk this is Startalk on
your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and today is a
cosmic queries primate Edition and we've
got an anthropologist who specializes in
primate behavior right in studio with us
with Natalia Reagan yeah
Natalia she'd like your brand-new one of
our star trek all-stars I'm very excited
welcome welcome to the club Chuck nice
hey it's good to have you as my co-host
of course donning a nine Stein t-shirt
indeed very nice and lately your your
your host of playing with science that's
correct
new spinoff of start off or start time
and you know why we spun this off I'll
tell you why because we did start
talking all manner of topics and some of
them would be sports and the sports ones
had their own following that's right and
we said let's do this let's feed them
let's feed those sports or see them
that's right let's just give them all
they want
it's Gary O'Reilly you know is a former
footballer yeah you a Brit footballer
footballer as they say as my daughter
cause it feetball feetball good because
football is in American sports so she
cause feet law and you know we we get
into all manner of science as it relates
to sports it's really cool and I wanted
to rename football cos no hardly any one
puts their foot on it what would you
call it yes yeah you catch it you run
with it run with it it's arm ball
exactly thought this through so there's
a cosmic where's primate addition so the
time you you've hung out with primates I
have on human primates presumably also
human primates human primates as well
there I tolerate the rogue
I actually stayed spider monkeys I
studied a critically endangered
subspecies of spider monkey called the
is where Oh spider monkey in Panama I
did like my main focus was conservation
so I actually was doing a census the
same year that we had our census in 2010
I was in Panama counting spider monkeys
and you find that the spider monkeys
were cooperative and filling out their
census forms they were not they were
very ornery like I had to chase these
guys down they threw fruit at me they
better than other things they could
throw at you I'm like why would they
poop in their hand and throw and all
they have to do is just gently position
their bottom right over your head and
just that's what that's what we call
getting baptized I mean they're they
like up here we have birds that do that
on your shoulder there you have monkeys
yeah yeah I'm never going yeah you got
spiders and you got howlers and the
funny thing is the diet you know
whatever you eat affects what kind
whatever comes out and I eat a lot of
fruit yes yeah we talked about how
spider monkeys are frugivores the that
it's our preferred food is fruit and
howler monkeys are followers meaning
they eat leaves and their poop stinks
I'm just telling you yeah we can smell
another before our they fall of or what
does that mean they eat leaves fall of
olive oil now and what if they're from
Brooklyn and they eat a lot of kale yeah
no so and so you worked among them did
you become one with them I wish man they
Jane Goodall of spider monkeys
funny thing is I god I wish no I know
some great spider monkey researchers
that would probably shouldn't take that
particular role but spider monkeys are
called the chimpanzees of the new world
because their social behavior is a lot
like chimps as far as they have big
groups and they fission off into smaller
groups and as far as your vision in
physics words
my duty to cause confusion yeah exactly
they fuse together in a sleeping tree at
the end of the night and then they
fission off to go eat and you know find
food elsewhere kind of like how chimps
do they'll have a big group and they'll
go off into smaller groups
isn't it true people don't want to
believe this but I think it's true I
read it on the internet that chimps and
humans are more genetically the chimps
and humans are more genetically alike
then either chimps or humans are
genetically related to the monkeys well
it's a common ancestor our common
ancestor was more recent between chimps
and humans and as far as that you have
to go farther back in time to get the
common ancestor between the common
answers that we had with chimps and all
the rest of the month around does that
makes with tales monkeys that apparently
some new world yeah new world monkeys
and those are the only ones by the way
all the great apes de temps like so
orangutangs and all those the great ape
list who was in apes chimps
there's bonobos orangutans mature those
those sexy ginger redheads in the
Southeast Asia tangs look like no I'm
just the whole movie series with
orangutan exactly with what's-his-face
but Clint yeah so that's why we know
orangutan Bill Maher we have one as
president oh man I wouldn't I don't know
I feel like that's really giving
orangutans a bad rap
I mean he has the flanges because the
male orangs have the flanges correct
wider cheek these are the pads right
here those are like the big flanges
flanges hey baby yeah face you know what
that comes from the mama orangutan is
going equally or else are just not like
one giant weird flange so do we have the
full list so well actually those of the
great apes it's humans humans gorillas
we didn't get gorillas chimps bonobos
right and then and and the earrings are
the south east any change and how about
the baboons are monkeys look at that do
they well some I mean they have a little
bit of a tail not I mean like they're
stumped to Helmick acts which don't have
tails but they are monkeys they are
macaques right so they're not part of
the yeah they're not yeah and I eaten
something out on the porch right in the
game Park huh and I turn around and come
back
baboon stole my bacon monkey you're
smart yeah very crafty and there's
actually great footage if you google it
of a numbering of a baboon taking down a
flamingo they actually will hunt and
kill and eat flamingos and it's prolly
taste like shrimp because they eat them
and there's a lesser apes oh by the way
I was going to throw in those great apes
and should be discriminating apes yeah I
know
Gibbons Gibbons have been small Gibbons
and then also there see amongst which
are the part of that group but they're a
little bit different they have a throat
sack and they're extremely loud Soula
howler monkeys which I was kind of
showing you that call before we started
filming well don't just share it with us
now you have now that you very
so I said do it I studied spider monkeys
but there also a lot of howler monkeys
where I worked in power howler
so they howl but you'll hear it's not so
much of a howl it sounds more of like
somebody clearing their throat in the
morning call howler monkey sometimes
they call back
let's hear sometimes they don't announce
let's go okay Eddie Murphy laughs so
does this make them horny or something
have you checked the book on this sound
no I know what you're doing to them
translation guide the Google translates
not that great but no it's it's it's how
they wake up in the morning and they'll
just kind of let one group know like hey
guys we're here oh it's a wake up saying
it's not just they do it the morning
good morning show so if you travel to
Central America or South America any
area or you know southern Mexico where
they have howler monkeys a lot of people
hear them in the morning like 5:00 a.m.
and they're like what's that like what
is that they think it's a Jaguar they
think they're like getting attacked this
is you all right it's just this little
monkey making it's loud and they have
these you know great throat sacks and
they're the fall of wars so what they do
is they let people or and let people
they let the other howler monkeys know
hey guys we're over here just just so
you know and they kind of communicate
that way so so I've read correct me if
I'm wrong that we speak we have the
power to create language because of a
genetic defect in whatever it is that
what makes apes make sounds that's what
I know that actually genetic mutation is
a single mutation instead of mutations
that an 800-seat separates us and allows
us to speak right yes it's awesome that
Israel allows us to then communicate
more complex ideas how to put it in a
book so now you don't have to know
everything in order to move civilization
forward absolutely stand on the
shoulders of those who came before you
yeah well there's been you know looking
at a speech if Neanderthals actually
were able to talk and there there's a
great special where they actually they
think that they might have been able to
but because of the way the
morphology of their questions on this
topic on brain primatology the internet
from Facebook and other sources
absolutely bring it on okay so here we
go let's defer everyone cuz I don't know
I don't know jack about you know I mean
other than humans being Apes ourselves
right you know more than the average
bear I don't know many bears that know a
lot about primates so maybe maybe that
wasn't a good you know more than the
average primate okay so what do you got
a check let's start off with Jared
Kellogg coming to us from Facebook and
Jared says this are primates still
evolving are there findings that show
human intervention whether habitat
change food change etc has changed how
they interact with each other and with
us well first of all everything's still
evolving nothing nothing has stopped
we're still evolving humans are and as
far as monkeys and apes yes I mean in
fact we talked about I have a rebuttal
today I wait or or where should I put it
in right now you put it in right now
right now so my rebuttal to that so so I
agreed that there's no evolution is
always a force at work but that doesn't
mean you're specie ating and here's
here's here's my point you can you can
split a species strand both branches
from one another now they can move
independently you come back in a million
years they're different right I get that
okay but right now all humans all over
the world can make babies yeah now if
we're all making babies then we are not
stranding any one branch of ourselves
and if we're all making babies at all
times doesn't that ossify who and what
we are in the Tree of Life
yeah because we have the coelacanth that
hasn't changed for how long fish got one
at the Museum of Natural History in a
cabinet so you see that like the the
cartilaginous bony right remains after
somebody I don't they hate it hate the
flesh my point is that you think of a
speciation when you when you isolate
branches is how you get the exotic
animals on so if we're not stranding
ourselves unless we put a colony on Mars
why would we think that one day we're
going to be something different well
it's not that we're going to be
something different it's just evolution
does not necessarily mean we're becoming
a new species it's just the way that we
are exchanging genes is causing you know
perhaps different you know it's it's
it's the genotype metamorphosis are is
is is is expressed in the phenotype
sometimes differently and as we
populations and as we're becoming this
very globalized world and populations
are mixing with other populations that
didn't in the past you know we're going
to see you know different expressions
you know whether it's you know in the
way we look or the way they all have
that together necessarily becoming new
species and I'm not saying that chimps
will become a new species as they're you
know let's get back to them so now we're
mess we're in their environment you know
you know we're spreading have they do
they have to adapt yeah of course I mean
and that's kind of the the idea that
it's sort of adapt or or or die or die
out you know and that's like we talked
about briefly I think last time was
macaque for instance last time say that
so I'm sorry there's a species of monkey
called macaques which are really
interesting because as far as a primate
goes they're the moat they're the second
most widely distributed preemie in the
world second to us humans and what
they're able to do is eat anything
they're like humans nearly yeah we're
like human little debris the big
dividing lines being able to in fact
there was a really great study coming
out NYU a grad student alloc Alex de
Cason hope I'm saying her last name rank
but in James hi I'm and another
researcher basically found that what you
eat is actually what is affecting brain
size it's not necessarily a primates
social skills and so diet has a lot to
do with not only as a matter of fact
there isn't that one of course when we
started using fire and and then roasting
meat and then getting bigger sources of
protein that caused our brains to become
larger yeah but not just meat because if
you think about it brains take a lot of
calories to function and so it's not
just about eating protein but also even
eating like carbohydrates like so being
able to cook tubers and roots and things
like that so the actual ability to eat
just keep eating yeah eating things that
are high and to thrive anywhere like
humans are amazing I mean we can live in
the Arctic and survive on I do and more
specialized your diet the more you are
in danger more susceptible you are right
actually when it comes to an interaction
like with your environment if say for
instance spider monkeys the ones that I
study with deforestation there's not a
lot of fruit available so it's it's
problematic you'll just go to Whole
Foods they can go right exactly
I can go hit the farm but that's the
thing is farmers market in the forest
that happens primates will actually
forage on other peoples on people's
property and eat their food at farms and
farmers will get mad and will attack and
kill them because they see them as a
threat to their livelihood
so we're livelihood really we came in
and took over their territory cold and
it's it's it's you see with orangutans
in fact you know farmers have killed
orangutans in the past because of just
them foraging for crops because they're
hungry I mean you would do it too we've
got to run a turns like highly
intelligent creatures oh yeah I mean
they're great they're great apes so like
us and they're they're they're really
good at imitation so they'll see
somebody like using a hammer and nail
and look over later on and there's the
rag to sort of you're not really
necessarily hammering it ASIS I thought
they were like you know toe
impress my Jay Leno would good money to
see that
so when I was a kid I'm old enough to
have seen Planet of the Apes in
first-run first-run theaters ok whole
damn
I did not see Planet of the Apes again
until like 40 years later right oh my
gosh that's a deeper movie yeah it is oh
my gosh and in it with the best ending
in the world in it in it the different
lines primates have different roles in
the society yes
so the orangutangs if i remember
correctly they were the diplomat as the
tip and the big thinkers the big figures
and the gorillas worthy ok guess who the
scientists were they were the ones
closest to the human you know I didn't
they were just all Apes when I saw the
movie right the Planet of the Apes and
so they actually did some some some some
thinkin some some dividing and splitting
yeah cuz I think I'm even in the most
recent one I remember watching it and
because most recent Planet of the Apes
movies yes and they had the same sort of
you know to the different groups of
great apes but I almost wish they could
take it a step further and I know I'm
just being a little too you know pointed
and you know particularly well that
stuff would be because they have
different social groups so like Reagan's
hands don't usually live in social
groups they live you know it's a single
mom with her infants than a single dad
and they both are kind of like solitary
but of course that doesn't make for a
very good movie if they're like where
are the orangutans clever screenwriters
they could possibly build that in what
you have a variation in something yeah
do something with it yeah a loner an
orangutan you talking to me anybody else
here must be talking to me oh god it's
him again another trouble
I take a break we'll come back and we'll
get a bunch more questions in on
primates as the topic with our special
guest Natalia Reagan anthropologist and
primate expert when we return we're back
on Startalk Neil Tyson here sometimes
with the de Grasse and be it's the grass
greener - the grass is greener and kneel
on the grass
Natalia Regan I keep calling Regan is
Regan Natalia Regan okay I'll answer any
answer to it so you your anthropologist
and you've worked in the field
specializing in spider monkeys but we
assume you have some osmotic knowledge
of other members of the primate
community world yes mate universe the
primate averse so what do you have Chuck
this classical query so you know we have
your questions here let's let's get
right into it
John Clemens wants to know this he's
asking you specifically Natalia do you
have a favorite primate oh gosh I feel
like I would be a total jerk if I didn't
say spider monkeys just because you
studied though they're pretty here I'm
gonna say a couple lame well actually
spider monkeys are pretty I think
fantastic now then here it is what
distinguishes them to make them high on
your list from all the other primates
well okay so I love the fact that we
talked about the frugivores thing that
they spider monkeys eat primarily fruit
the ones that I studied in Panama were
so tenacious as far as the deforestation
problem in Panama it's bad and I saw
spider monkeys groups living in what
should be a corridor between two huge
fragments living in just the corridor so
they were able to scrap together a
living and by living I mean food and and
still had infants you know on their back
and on their front you know I one and I
two those are the different stages of
infancy and so they were still able to
make it in this really degree they
reorganized their civilization to still
survive in spite of what humans are
doing
yes and they also sound like one of the
cool actually working on nuclear weapons
SpiderMonkey with the codes and they
have they have the prehensile tails all
they had to do is just kind of like
prehensile means it can grip if it's
actually a prehensile and only new world
monkeys by the way have that and not all
of them only a few do but also this is
an interesting fact spider monkey the
judge of that I think you'll like it
female spider monkeys have the
hypertrophic clitoris hypertrophic means
what is this other word you see so what
is so these are spider monkeys these are
spider monkeys and females real spider
webs they have it basically looks like
almost an index finger for hanging down
it's a dangler it's a pseudo penis and
it looks like it would be I the first
time I ever saw a female spider monkey I
thought oh those are some male spider
monkeys which I was told no no no no no
these were so hypertrophic means to
bigger
yeah well it's extending from the body
okay what is the purpose of that's the
thing is it's there's not there's
there's different ideas of what that
could be but there's no actual accepted
theory about why there is the
hypertrophic litoris one of them is that
it makes it easy to identify females
from a far distance because it really
does I mean it helps us researchers I
know from if I have binoculars I see it
the dangler so what does the male penis
do that the male penis actually I mean
it's actually not too smooth not too
shabby itself I actually have seen some
populations in the field and by the way
spider monkeys have very long copulation
compared to ours yes welcome to monkey
porn they have very long copy licks they
actually hit a right at entry in the
primatology cold encyclopedia that's
coming out on intro mission pattern and
copulatory mixture which is basically
monkey sex positions right the lay
person but I had to talk about how long
spider monkeys will engage and it's
usually on the upwards of like 20
minutes really how they can be for a
very long time I have - oh that right
there is a high
taina pseudo penis that's a female and
it's a female hyena right the clitoris
and actually hyenas give birth through
their clitoris and for those of you who
are do not have the benefit of Startalk
all-access calm right now we are looking
at a picture that is up on a scream it
is a female hyena who is just dating
right now she's pregnant and she has a
hypertrophic clitoris interests yeah and
and the clears doubles as the birth
canal I mean that's what men say like
all I could never have a child because
that kid you imagine you know giving
birth through her urethra meet the hyena
can't feel great okay maybe it does
maybe yeah you're right you know maybe
maybe I right baby it's like well that's
nature's word for them I'm just saying
okay let's let's go to juco von ihnen
van menon okay from hell sent Helsinki
Finland what's your guess other primates
in the Trappist one system that's to you
Neal and I think he just once this is
trying to find a way we get to ask you
about Trappist one that's so the
Trappist one is a star system it has
seven recently discovered earth-like
planets three of which are orbiting in
the Goldilocks zone okay where there's
not too hot not too cold you can sustain
liquid water that's about all we know
right now these planets do cross the
front the surface of the cross between
us and our sight line to the host star
there's a cottage industry ready to
blossom where we will study the
ingredients of the atmospheres of these
planets by analyzing the light of the
host star as it passes through that
atmosphere and so then you can say odors
have oxygen is there methane is there
any of this other stuff so so what we
don't know we can't look at the surface
yet but we are in search of biomarkers
okay so what we would do to answer that
question take it seriously is we would
ask you metalia
is there any effect that primates have
on their atmosphere so that when we
study the chemical composition of the
atmosphere we can say it's got primates
mmm-hmm
that would be the question Wow because
if it has methane for example maybe
there's a farming industry because
methane is a byproduct of farms or
Mexican food ingredient of flatulence
does it have termites there there's you
know maybe it's not uniquely implicating
them but it couldn't be suggestive of it
so from what you know do primates have
any special impact on their environment
well what they do I mean it's not so
much I think the atmosphere as far as
air bud so for instance we talked about
spider monkeys eating fruit or other
monkeys eating fruit that is a way they
are actually distributors of those seeds
so same way peas pollinate flowers they
carry the the seed the fruit and they
actually they eat the whole fruit
including the seeds you can't digest the
seed right so that comes out and they
poop it out and this is the plants
diabolical plan right to spread their
seeds right yeah there was one theory
that I read years ago about how you can
imagine the plant scientists saying okay
we're gonna prove how do we get a list
put it through the entire digestive
system of a bear we have to make the
casing strong enough so did resist the
digestive things right then they'll poop
it over here poop it over there and we
can spread like yep
no I actually I would I hosted a Bigfoot
show years ago called Bigfoot bounty and
we found and we'd had the contestants
going out looking for biomaterials that
could be Bigfoot poop basically and
there was one turd that I found I will
never forget this turd that is a sense
I'd never thought I would hear in my
life there's one turd I never thought
I'd see right there there's a beautiful
turd it was purple and I just looked at
it man it was clearly a bear turd but it
was all just blackberries it was just
like it is it it was just all seed it
almost looked like it was like a candy
confection thing but it was a
I did not please whatever you do don't
ruin candy for me have very few things
left in my life sorry about that yeah so
see distribution and um you know
obviously what we'd have to do is we we
need more than the atmosphere we need
some other geographic data environmental
DNA is very interesting like they'll
leave behind like our if something is a
for instance bites or stings them or not
bite stings but more bites like a blood
sucking insect we can dissect their
blood meal and find if there are
primates
Jurassic Park I saw there this is
actually no no we can do ecological
surveys now like that ok my kidding so
they so this is their DNA remnants from
various things that happen what's his
blood that's in the like safe of
mosquito bites ok so your DNA signature
is outside of yourself in some way that
was very cool
what else you got check here we go let's
talk about Antonio Rodriguez who wants
to know this are their primate hybrids
yes Oh primate hybrids hybrids been
hybridized hybridized a bouns actually
back to and they are able to produce
offspring so you know it's funny the
center yes it's half-horse half-man ok
then the Minotaur
that's just weird it's it's half-man
half-bull but the rear it's a it's it's
a human but yes it's just weird it's all
human up to the waist so it's got a
human butt so weird it's just that's it
don't think that through I know
very top-heavy - no but we're talking
about blending jeans of course so are
they are the great apes close enough to
one another genetically that they can
crossbreed no no and that's the thing so
baboons are able there's multiple
species of baboon that are able to do
that okay but we still call them all
baboons
well yeah but they're different species
of baboons so there's you know the olive
baboons there's Mohammed Reyes there's
gelada baboons which okay so fantastic
but that's not interesting I know as far
as like of a chimp and a gorilla
that's even better know that having
violated mate a lot of things can meet
with each other but I don't think they'd
actually produce viable offspring no
okay we haven't seen that
how about chimps and bonobos well that's
the thing chips in a moment of bonobos
are been up bonobos probably could they
haven't seen any I think hybrid hybrids
coming graphically where do we find them
well that's the thing is they do have
some overlaid bonobos are only in DRC
Democrat Democratic Republic of Congo
formerly Zaire chimps are in multiple
places throughout Africa DRC they're in
Republic of Congo and just various
places throughout in Western see by the
way is a very famous wine just so you
know really domain de la romanée-conti
right there's too many syllables for
Americans we just called DRC
oh is it pretty burgundy okay well we
should do or CS a while they're
winemakers robos it's also probably why
they're making love all the time my
females they want their wine and they
want their sweet love but as far as them
and mixing with chimps I don't know of
any studies that have come out but there
was a species of well known it was it
was a chimp a group of chimps in an area
of DRC that they they were so large that
they thought they could be a hybrid of
gorillas and chimps it turns out they're
just chimps but
a good friend of mine actually gym
memberships CrossFit chips that's too
much there that's too much all right
he's looking over your shoulder so
you're not supposed to do that all right
as humans are we progressing no let's
forget that one okay okay as humans are
we Chris Chris Snyder as humans are we
progressing forward or are we idling
with all the technology that is so
easily available in other words are we
going to evolve because of our
technology like will that turn us into
different humans and thereby different
further separating us from our primates
what we can do is we can turn ourselves
into super humans and then turn chimps
into humans I think there's an ethical
question there's probably not a good
idea no ships are really aggressive I
don't know if I don't want them like
taking out my trash well is there any
attempt to in the in the spirit of that
question is the attempt to modify their
DNA to make them more capable of
surviving their environment in one way
or another yeah not that I know of no I
mean like modifying their DNA no I mean
even like the the new gene editing we
have in humans like spur and there's a
new one that I read about recently
that's even you could actually inject a
living person with editing genes that
are supposed to take effect
it worked on lab rats but that's run
into a lot of ethical questions but as
far as trying to change living primates
to better adapt no it's just mostly
trying to change human behavior so they
can live longer
you know I hopefully push you know what
for instance like an orangutans with
deforestation we're trying to get people
not to use palm oil because that's a big
problem there so things like that we're
trying to
amend our behavior rather than expecting
them to just sort of like change your
diet become a new speaker what's wrong
with palm oil well palm oil plantations
are basically a big cause of
deforestation in for whatever was there
before that's exactly the palm oil
itself is not a bad thing it's just the
way it's been cut it down we cut down a
bunch of trees so that we can actually
raise palm oil yeah I love me some
coconut oh yeah no no I go way back
coconut take a break
you've been listening to and some of you
may have even been watching this episode
of star talk
cosmic queries primate edition who with
anthropologist Natalia Reagan when we
come back we're back on Startalk cosmic
queries primate edition yes humans are
primates just in case you didn't know
you're animals
yes and even if you didn't know we were
animals your momma told you what they
say what the parents what the teachers
say to kids who don't yet know they're
gonna be professional comedians they'll
say something in class and the teachers
what do you what are you a comedian I
wish I could go back to every single
time that happened to my I kid you not
meal I actually dream of being able to
get into a time machine first thing if I
invent the time machine
we'll get that squared out 'yes then
we'll solve world world problems and
believe me it would go just like this
what are you some kind of comedian the
tire Regan so you're here to help us
answer your questions on planets came
through our social media network so give
me more okay here we go Don Rama from
facebook says this judging from the
study of Coco the gorilla do you believe
that primates and other animals are
capable of higher learning good question
there's a good question um so not just
coke Coco there's multiple examples of
non-human primates so Coco was a gorilla
and also some chimpanzee ones to Washoe
yeah there's been a show what's wrong
yeah that's right yeah so the yeah there
as far as cognitive
abilities there's a lot that non-human
primates can do and there's been studies
not just having to do sign language and
things of that sort but actually being
able to understand and remember patterns
they found that chimps were actually
better at doing some of those pattern
memory tests than actual humans were so
there are a lot of abilities that I
think non-human primates have in terms
of cognition but we also have to
remember that measuring cognition and
animals is not just about being able to
you know do algebra or calculus it's
about you know social intelligence and
being able to communicate in ways that
works for them because it's not about
adapting and surviving in our world it's
about adapting and surviving in the air
world maybe if they had a need for
algebra they would actually understand a
development understanding about but they
don't have a need for it that would be
scary no ape doing better on math my
math test than I am SATs and me so do
you know Carl Sagan's famous quote I
think it was in reference to dolphins
but he could easily be applied to chimps
it was we have found some dolphins that
have managed to make gestures that make
it clear that they understand what we're
talking about but we have yet to find
any human that can speak dolphin we are
so species centric in so many ways
that's good try to talk to cats man but
I don't know if they get me you know
like I try to understand what oh they
get you they're just ignoring you
that's a cat you see the xkcd comic
about that no okay I can't I got a left
first before I even say it okay so this
guy comes home alright and there's a cat
sitting on the edge of the couch right
then obviously just came home from his
day and the caption is if cats could
talk okay so he comes into hi kitty
witty how are you and the cat looks up
and just goes perfect the best comic
rats could talk that's perfect it just
looks up and they just look
give me some cosmic queries alright here
we go
evolution is at a cellular level this is
from Michele Tapia DNA writes our shape
adding it here and there can change you
okay thanks so much is that really what
evolution is though ask the question is
that indeed what evolution is change on
a cellular level yeah well I mean it's
it's it's the passing down of different
genetic material and it does it starts
at a cellular level but it also you know
it doesn't necessarily manifest itself
immediately you know the genes are
passed down it might actually be seen
generations from now that you you know
had been in your family for four
generations but it's also not goal
driven well wait but if I'm born with
six fingers that sixth finger is not
just a cell that's a whole thing body
and now I got the sixth finger gene
weird mutation yeah yeah yeah and if I
start making babies with other
six-fingered may double partners we're
going we can start a new base twelve
arithmetic system it's right the most
awesome piano players in the world my
gosh you just be the fastest I play the
sitar better than anybody you've ever
seen all right here we go why do
apes retain or perpetuate the Kindred
instinct no signs of actual hate or feud
against each other and us humans appear
to have lost this identity but is that
true about other Apes I see yeah oh yeah
yeah chimps will kill one another so is
there a bar there eight muggings just
the rest of what's in your wallet here
your food for them currency is food
like I actually I've done a video on
this about how you know chimps will give
gifts of fruit in hopes of getting a
little extra side nookie just because
that's what that is
for Nikki well it's kind of like buying
your sweetheart a necklace or something
like that it's it's an exchange it's an
exchange but anyways back to the
question it is cheaper than diamonds hey
baby his arms you know what here's a few
grapes on me just to make it even
sweeter only life for that simple
oh gosh but yeah as far as altruism and
kindness there is that in the animal
world we see that in multiple species
not just in primates human and non-human
but there is aggression chimpanzees are
known for a lot of you know in group
fighting mm-hmm I'll have you know alpha
male they're done more to more you know
I but the thing is we we don't like to
get lost on the blue oh my god you don't
wear blue in this part of the forest
West Side Story so they'll have
coalition's where they actually they'll
circle their territory and if they see a
chimp from a nearby group that they that
shouldn't be there they will attack and
they will kill and sometimes they will
do things like each that particular
chimp yeah it could be pretty buddy but
this is like yeah this is I will eat
your heart and get your strength that
you had I don't know who my favorite
primate is but I'm quickly finding out
who my least favorite is but also we
have to remember even though they can be
very aggressive so are humans in some
ways but we are we are way more
cooperative as our chimps then
aggressive I think because I'm balanced
yeah I mean cuz we I mean otherwise it
would just they would all be dead
exactly operation is a big part of who
we are and other primates you know a
whole year and not want to kill anyone
let's get this one in there somewhere a
lightning round because a guy Zachary
Aaron cluster wants to know this
can you explain some of the stranger
mating dominance rituals that various
primates do I'm thinking about
Silverbacks as well as baboons about
some of these rituals
well primate mating rituals mating a
rich I don't know if there's so much a
ritual but there's just the way they way
to go about it orangutan is one of the
things that people don't know is it's
males or solitary females for it's
usually alone with whatever infant they
have and it can be get a little rough if
a female is not interested in a male
males will do well force copulation
mm-hmm and so that yeah which is happens
that's terrible just rape it would be
their combined is that what they owe God
it is it sports copulate this happens it
does happen and it yeah so so I mean the
male is stronger than the female yes and
so there's sexual dimorphism sexual
dimorphism means that there's a size
difference between males and females on
average between exactly like you know
black widows I mean have you ever seen a
male black widow probably not because
they're so small they're so lame oh my
god so any other like primate meaning of
actual rich I mean like you know funny
rituals no no what about the okay is is
this the baboon on whose butt gets
inflamed and red so yeah in fact I have
a friend of mine baboon but yeah I know
baboons and my friend is actually right
now on her way to Zambia to do research
Megan Peters Dorf and she actually will
be it she said it in New York University
but she will be looking at sexual
swellings of baboons and she's at my
friend Todd DISA tell also of NYU
they developed a laser system so they
can actually measure the size of her
swollen these are metrics to measure the
size of this swollen vulva and it's a
single signal to the opposite sex that
they are ready to get down that is a
scientific term you can tell your
friends and family but yeah chimps have
the same sexual swellings bonobos as
well we'll get these sexual spellings
when they eat well they don't have humor
it's not a heat thing oh well we have
ovulate we have concealed ovulation
which is a whole nother oh that's a
whole nother show which is very
interesting in there's different
theories of why we have you can't unless
you really know your partner or you
could you know you can Huff it on them
you can smell like oh something's up you
was like honey it's you know I would say
let's make love but I'm pretty sure
you're ovulating no we do not people
that do the whole you know the rhythm
method and that's kind of stuff but it's
I'm intrigued that among primates
counting us with this group that they
have concealed we have concealed
ovulation and others don't
because the other primates do not have
child custody cases
well it's interesting and a lot of those
primate species that have the sexual
swellings they do live in large groups
so if for instance somebody does give
birth and you don't know who it was at
Steve JimBob who knows the village or
basically they take it's okay
they don't necessarily you know Jerry
Springer like us no guy wants to answer
the door hey what's up hey man I'm here
to pick up your wife and kids Mubeen
Ahmed wants to know this can monkeys be
lunatics yes
[Music]
monkeys can act a little crazy oh yeah
and go off the ranch yes they can be
there's are there are those outliers
that you know and there's even
freeloading monkeys monkeys that take
too much and don't give back that other
monkeys will kind of spurn next one go
all right Petros in zoos ULA's wants to
know this how can all Homo sapiens be
nearly genetically identical to each
other we're not all Homo sapiens
into
breeded with Neanderthal well just to
put it clear as I as I remember it
there are Europe especially but their
branches of the human species that have
more Neanderthal than others yes if you
only have a four if you're only of
African descent and have no Antonio
Neanderthal but they're all they also
have a new there's Denisovans which are
a group that lived in Asia that are that
basically are found in populations in
Asia and Melanesia and then there's also
a new unknown DNA that they don't know
they don't have fossil evidence for that
also add mixed with humans but they're
found in like Australia and what does it
mean for us to be close to one another
but some have Neanderthal and others
don't what basically it means where's a
founder population in Africa there's
more genetic to variable diversity
between those with living within or that
are from Africa hmm and then those that
have spread out so okay so we are
different on the level that these
differences manifests but we can all
still interbreed of course yeah yeah
yeah small dish was a very small sample
of humans that Ed mixed with
Neanderthals it was not a lot it was not
like it wasn't happening every you know
as Todd my I had a Neanderthal show this
weekend he brought up the fact that it
they think it was you know only a
several thousands of thousands of
instances of admixture well it's not a
ton of DNA that got into our system so
for some people you get to say you stop
being a Neanderthal because I think
that's actually some of that in them
right there but Neanderthals weren't all
that bad we have a sympathizer so much
why don't you marry one we gotta bring
that to a halt here the tyre Regan thank
you for being on Startalk and Chuck hey
always good to have you it's good to be
here and when you're not with me you're
with you're you're with Gary O'Reilly
okay let's not really like that you're
playing with science with call me
sometime okay I feel deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist as always
bidding you
to keep looking up this is Startalk
[Music]